I watched through my peripheral vision
it's something that I learned to do in
the military I learned to stand at
attention
and look straight forward
but still see what's going on around me
and I could see
I could see the honor guard take the
flag off of his coffin
their sharp uniforms
they're white gloves
I watched their crisp well-rehearsed
movements as they went through their
procedures
without shifting my eyes
I focused back on his coffin
I was still trying to process it all so
much emotion so much joy so much sorrow
so much light and laughter and love
so much life
all now boxed up and silent
in that wooden casket
gone
the honor guard continued with their
predetermined movements
one fold at a time
precise hands moving like Craftsmen
as they carry on the red and white
stripes of the flag are consumed by the
blue field with its white stars
flag is finely folded
into a neat thick triangle
the leader of the honor guard a second
class petty officer grasps the flag into
his hands
he executes a sharp facing movement
takes a step and then executes another
face and movement
he's now looking directly at me our eyes
are locked
but expressionless
we both know we have a job to do
he marches forward
he halts just in front of me
I slowly and precisely raise my right
hand from my side and render a sharp
salute
I pause
I gradually lower the salute and then
put my hands out to receive the flag
he moves It Forward into my hands
I clench it
the flag is heavy in my hands with pain
and grief
I feel the weight
a weight I can barely support as it
tears at my soul
he takes one step back
and renders a slow Flawless salute
it is my turn now
I execute a right face
I take six steps forward
I focus on my breath
I clench my jaw in order to get some
control over my emotions before she sees
my face
I execute another right face
I am in front of her now
I take two steps forward
she Whispers a quiet moan of anguish
it is the loudest noise I have ever
heard
I stop in front of her still looking
straight ahead
I bend down onto one knee
I look at her
heart is broken
tears are trickling down her face
and yet she smiles at me
as if to say
it's okay
I feel my emotions start to rush to the
surface I want to break down I want to
cry
but there is procedure to follow
and I am a military man and I know to
follow procedure
I then say the words
on behalf of the president of the United
States the United States Navy
and a Grateful Nation
please accept this flag as a symbol of
our appreciation of your loved ones
honorable
and faithful service
I place the full weight of that flag
with all its Agony and torment into her
hands
she looked down at it and pulled it in
close to her chest and absorbed it all
then she looked back at me
I break protocol
your boy was my hero I told her
I loved him
and I always will
she smiled
and she nodded
she already knew that
her eyes returned to gaze at the heavy
flag in her arms
I leaned in and gently kissed her on the
forehead
that kiss was not only from me
she knew that too
I stood back up
and assumed the position of attention
I rendered the proudest salute I could
possibly muster
I took one step back
I performed a right face
and I marched off and assumed my
position back in the ranks
the guns were fired
the bugle played its solemn notes
then my friend was buried in that sacred
place
with many of my other friends
our brothers in arms
now together again
and above it all
soaring in the sky was our flag
Old Glory
bearing upon it the weight of a million
Souls who gave their lives for it
bearing upon it the burden and anguish
of mothers and fathers who gave their
precious children for it
and yet it flies
it flies carried Aloft by freedom
and by the precious memories of those
who sacrificed everything to give us
that freedom
please
remember what that Flag represents
and why it flies